hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar fully humanized mouse models for
immuno-oncology pre-clinical drug
candidate selection
i am antonina salcido of labrutz and i
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by miltoni biotek
to learn more please visit
miltonybiotech.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting as many questions as you may
have during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
sebastian tabra
cso trans at transfer bioservices
sebastian you may now begin your
presentation
hello it's a pleasure to welcome you for
this webinar my name is sebastian tamron
i'm the cso of transgender bioservices
and in collaboration with meeting
biotech
i would be happy today to to guide you
through the use of the human life's mice
for immunoencouraging pre-clinical
research
so just few words about transcript
bioservices
10 years ago we started this cro we are
now based in france 70 collaborators
including 21 phd and we really have
focused our company on developing a more
predictive advanced mouse model and
among them the two
most important model i would say are the
humanization of the immune systems i'll
focus my talk today
on this model
but also the humanization of the liver
so the ability to reconstitute human
hepatocytes a fully humanized liver in a
rodent model
so let's go back to the humanization of
the immune system
so being able to
animals
give a tougher tools to then use those
models
for different disease
platforms disease model
the subject of today would be immune
oncology but we have gathered
tons of data over the years on the use
of those animals for infectious disease
we have a bsl2 bsl3 animal and lab
facility where we can conduct hiv hpv
related experiment
model of inflammation
ibd
asthma
fibrosis of the lung of the liver
gvhd so all these models could be
used to determine efficacy of action of
a compound
the toxicity the immune toxicity can be
also assessed in humanized mice it's
become being more and more important
nowadays to assess if your therapy
will induce cytokine release syndrome
over activation of the t cells and so on
and being able to do it in the context
of a full human immune system is very
important
so this slides really summarize what we
mean by advanced human immune system
mouth mother
we start from highly immunodeficient
animals not skin and to receptor gamma
mutated animals
those animals do not have any bt or nk
cells from urine origin so you only
get some residual macrophages that are
partially defective because of the il
receptor two gamma mutation
those animals are very good recipient
for engraftment with hematopoietic stem
cells so cd34 positive cells are
engrafted into those animals we let the
system maturate for 14 weeks and we end
up with a mouse that has a full human
immune systems
from the dendritic cells the monocytes
the nk the the b lymphocytes all the
cells are there
functional able to interact with each
other
the first step
when you want to humanize animals it's
to have good hematopoietic stem cells
and the purification of the
hematopoietic stem cells from cold blood
is performed using the multimax
from miltoni so using this machine in
combination
with the cd34 micro beat kits
we are able to achieve a positive
selection of the hematopoietics and stem
cells with a high purity of a 95 percent
with less than 2 percent
of contaminating human cd3
and the ability of getting a high purity
of hematopoietic stem cells is really
key to get good humanized animals that
will not develop gvhd over the time
the protocol that we use to humanize
those animals is depict on this slide
the first step is to make room in the
bone marrow
and to do that we have choose a protocol
and optimize a protocol that is based on
chemo ablation so we use
bisoul fan to make room in the bone
marrow of those animals before the
engraftment of the metapoetic stem cells
the choice of
using the chemo ablation rather than
irradiation
is based on the fact that irradiation
are known to cause anemia over the time
into those animals so you have more
robust animals using the chemoablation
protocol animals that
are stable over the time for the health
but also for the humanization rate
the second advantage that we have is
that we produce those mice in advance
so you don't have to wait 14 weeks to
start your experiment about 200 animals
are humanized every week just to cope
with the demand so you can really start
your experiment right after signature
those animals have been qc by flow
cytometry and the main immune cells
population have been characterized
all these human immune cells do express
what they are supposed to express in
terms of receptor
this is a non-exhaustive list of
different markers that we use we say in
the day-to-day to characterize
the main immune cells population
but really the take-home message from
this slide is we need that every time
that we look at the different markers
that markers is expressed by the cell of
interest so no hole in the system
and
thanks to the the pickup fridge from
miltoni it's a really great tool to have
easily access to antibodies we can set
up
new panels for customers optimize those
panels up to 14 colors per panel
to really decipher how the human immune
systems do react into those animals
humanized mice as i say has a full have
a full reconstitution of all the immune
cells population
but nevertheless one drawback is the
fact that
myeloid dendritic cells
even nk cells are poorly reconstituted
into those animals
the strategy that we have choose to
develop and optimize over the year is
based on a technique called aerodynamic
gene delivery
using large volume of
saline solution that contain plasmid
coding for those human growth factors
we can get a very
transient at the
very moderate level expression of human
cytokines we have optimized different
cocktails for myeloid for dendritic
cells for nk cells as you can see on
this slide
expression of cytokines will last for
few days then goes back to the normal
but this transient expression of
cytokines
will have a profound and stable impact
on the cell lineage that you want to
boost into those animals
so on this slide we can compare what is
the normal situation so non-boosted
animals you mostly have t and b cells
percentages of nk mono dendritic cell
are quite low
thanks to the boost with the different
cocktails of cytokines
we can increase the percentages of
monocytes of dendritic cells up to 20
percent
but also the amount of anti-cells within
the system
we have also validated the fact that we
can combine the two boost into the same
animals to get a little bit more of
everything and being more
close to what is the situation in a real
patient
looking at percentages is
cool it's very informative but sometimes
percentages could be misleading so
having access to absolute count
is also key to
know what you are doing working with
those humanized minds
you can see on this graph
absolute number of cells per ml of blood
before after the boost
blacked out where we can show an
increase in the absolute nerve level of
myeloid cells monocytes
we have also investigated conventional
plasmacyto dendritic cells dc type 1 dc
type 2 all these cells were quite
difficult to observe in non-boosted
animals but thanks to the booths we can
now set up protocols studies
that use those cells for the mechanism
of action
peripheral blood is great of course
that's easy to
interrogate without sacrificing the
animals but it's really just the tip of
the iceberg
we know that the major organs are indeed
infiltrated with human immune cells
so thanks to the gentle max
octodissociator from miltoni in
combination with various
tissue dissociation kits
we can get cell suspension out of any
organs from these animals
so we have characterized
the humanization rate and humanization
quality of the spleen the liver
the bone marrow the intestine the brain
the lung
really a comprehensive picture of what
is inside those animals boosted
non-boosted um
and all these compartments why are they
important because they are really
providing a source of human immune cells
that can be mobilized when you challenge
those animals for example with a tumor
another example on this slide now
looking at nk south population
in boosted non-boosted animals boosted
here with il-15 that not only increase
the total amount of empty cells in
peripheral blood but also the proportion
of these cells expressing cd16
you can also observe on this slide the
stability of the boost so this is the
situation before the boost one two
percent max of nk cells thanks to the
boost we increase that to five six seven
percent and this is stable up to two
months
we have validated the fact that if more
time is needed we can apply a second
boost and then therefore gain
for five my four five months sorry of um
of higher rate of anticipated monocycle
dendritic cells
so let's now discuss about what can be
done
in the context of immuno oncology so
what can be done to assess efficacy
mechanism of action safety of your drug
acting
on the growth of the tumors
via
immune cells or we also have customers
that wants to see and you will have
examples about that
how by targeting the tumor cells
specifically there is also a
contribution of the immune cells
so we start of course with these human
eyes mines boosted non-boosted if we
have to boost the animals the animal is
boosted one week before the engraftment
of the tumor
tumor and grafted most of the model that
we have developed are based on sub-q
engraftment but we start to have more
and more auto-topic
mouse model as well
the growth of the tumor is followed
either by caliper or by bioluminescence
if we have a tumor that exports
luciferase for example
we follow the growth of the time we can
collect blood
at different time points for pt analysis
when the tumor reach
the ethical limit we do sacrifice the
animals collect whatever needs to be
collected and
analyze uh by flow cytometry to to
decipher how the immune systems do react
to the treatment
most of the tumor that grow in
non-humanized mice in nude mice
can be grown as well in human eyes mice
as a rule of thumb i would say that
about 19 95 percent of all the tumors
that grow well in
a nude mice will grow eventually
in humanized mice but what you can see
on this
slide is
that the immune system will react anyway
to the tumor that you do in graft and it
can react on both way on both sides you
can either fight the tumor that's the
case for melanoma cells known to be
quite
immunogenic
so those tumors will grow slower in
humanized minds compared to
non-humanized bites but for some other
tumors you can have the earlier way
around the opposite situation
glioblastoma
will grow faster in humanized mice
compared to non-humanized mice
it really shows you here
that you have the two-phase of the kind
approaching or the anti-tumor action of
the immune system so without working
with io related drugs you can see here
that the human immune system that is
reconstituted is able to
to interact
with the tumor and create some micro
environment
so those tumors are indeed infiltrated
by immunohistochemistry we can show that
we have all the facilities in the house
to perform ihc chromogenic or
fluorescence you have here an example
with cd4 cd8
positive human cells
at the vicinity but also at the center
of the tumor so it's a
very homogeneous infiltration by human
immune cells but you will see in few
slides that is that this infiltration is
largely dependent of the cdx that you do
implants
hc is great but for most of our
customers they want to
have a more thorough investigation of
how the immune cells infiltrate the
tumor are activated within the tumor so
definitely flow cytometry
key to go in the direction
so combining the flow cytometry
capabilities that we have with three
flow cytometers up to 14 channel in each
of them
with the gentle dissociator and the
human tumor dissociation kit
we can get single cell suspension out of
a tumor and analyze everything by flow
to get a more comprehensive picture of
how those human immune cells
played a role
we can do that
after before treatment of course but we
can also use that technology to
characterize better the different models
the different cdx pdx model that we
propose to our customer
on this slide
you see hot versus cold tumor
example of hot tumor and dmb 231 more
than 5 million of human immune cells per
gram of tumor that's a lot compared to
rko colon carcinoma
only 3 000 human immune cells per gram
of tumor so you see that the window
where you can play hard versus cold it's
quite large and we have customers that
wants to face thing to face
more challenging tumors with less
infiltration or we have customers that
wants to start for example with a tumor
that is well infiltrated just as a proof
of concept
amount of cells
quantity of cells is important but
of course we can do better and the
quality of the immune system
is also characterized so we have about
30 35 different cdx models where we have
this kind of data
and we can use those data to suggest
the best model to our customers based on
their mechanism of action so
as you can see on this slide we have
some tumors that are infiltrated mostly
with t-cells cd4 cd8
some tumors do have t-rex some tumors do
not have any t-rex some tumors are
highly infiltrated with macrophages some
do not have at all some tumors have a
large proportion of np cells so maybe
great models for adcc related activity
so can really play with all these cdx
models to recommend the most appropriate
model based on the
mode of action
another interesting
feature of these humanoids mice is the
fact that
the t cells in naive anymore
non-challenged animals the t-cells are
quite
acquired so you do not have exertions or
over-activation of the cells that's also
why you don't get gvhd of all the time
into those animals
but the good news is that once those
cells start to infiltrate the tumor and
you have here an example with hct 116
tumor cells
those cells start to express markers of
activation exhaustions uh pd1 cd68 uh
t-gate and so on so those uh
those immune cells are really able to do
the job migrate the tumor and modify the
phenotype accordingly
the first example here using mdmb231
to
to give you two messages the first one
is as you can see on this graph
that already with n equals five so five
animals per group you can get very
significant data a very good tgi here
using
toxo rubicin has a positive control so
that the first technical message is that
humanized mice will not increase the
viability of your response
sometimes we have scientists that do
fear
to to start working with humanized mice
because of the high variability really
the viability is more coming from the
cdx model than the humanized mice per se
the second message from this experiment
is that just by inducing apoptosis of
the tumor cells
and therefore release of antigenic
material this is already sufficient to
induce
a dramatic infiltration of human immune
cells you get more dendritic cells more
nk cells and even the switch the m1 and
2 macrophages balance
so just by
targeting directly the tumor cells you
can see and imagine how
you will get a better comprehension of
what's going on in patients because here
you are working in the context of a free
humanized system
humanized mice uh
have a lot of success working with
immune checkpoint inhibitors as a
monotherapy or even a combination
therapy so we have screened the
different cdx tumor model
for the expression of pdl-1 we can do
that by flow cytometry in vitro we also
have data
by ihc to characterize the expression of
pdl1
in vivo in the context of the human
immune system
so once those models have been
characterized we started to see how
those model could respond
uh to a treatment based on immune
checkpoint inhibitors for our first
example here with an antipedia one so
using kit frida 10 milligrams per kick
treating a gastric tumor cdx implanted
sub-q
what you can see here that you have a
significant but
still modest tgi with 10 milligrams per
kick of anti-pd1
this is something that we do observed a
lot
working in the context of humanized mice
you will never get 100
tgi
with immune checkpoint therapy as a
monotherapy so immune checkpoint in
bitter alone will never give you more
than 30 35 tgi even if
you use what we call a responsive cdx
and the reason is that if you look at
individual curve here's an example with
anti-cta4
you see untreated animals treated with
epd member for 20 mix per cake you can
see that two animals the response very
well 100 tgi while the other animals do
not respond at all so it's really
mimicking what was what is the situation
in patient with some patient responding
very well to these new therapies while
some other the treatment failed we still
don't know
why but not only you have access to
tumor growth inhibition efficacy of your
compound but thanks to the teals
analysis
you will also get insight
in how the immune cells do react
after treatment with anti-ct a4 for
example
you can observe an increase of the cda t
cells within the tumor and as a
expected a reduction of the human t-rex
within those tumor
most of the cdx most of the pdx if you
treat them
with a monotherapy based on immune
checkpoint inhibitors you will get
very few percentage of tgi sometimes
nothing at all that's the example here
using a375 melanoma cell lines
it's really in red no efficacy at all
the blue curve is a t-cell engager
provided by one of our customers a very
modest tgi as well but when you combine
both so when at the same time
you release the braking you push on the
metal to
boost the immune
system then you get the best
and you get a very synergistic very
significant tgi by combination of the
catrida and the t-cell engager
so this is one example another example
of this uh combination therapy and the
synergistic effect that you can observe
in humanized minds
is depict on this slide so 1 root 16
left untreated treated to event type pd1
you can clearly see that one animal do
respond very well to the treatment
the five other animals do not respond at
all
but when you combine the entire pd1 with
monoclonal antibodies targeting the
surface rcd47 pathway pathway that is
used by a motorcycle macrophage through
the job
then you get once again a very
synergistic effect
with almost 100 tgi
so innate immunity
milo itself
dendritic cells nk cells
the functionality of these cells could
be assessed as well in humanized ones
that's the key advantage of those
humanized mice compared to pbmc in
grafted animals where you just take pbmc
from adults you infuse those pbmc into
immunodeficient animals after few days
you only get t cells in the system so
only the biology the functionality of
the t cells could be assessed
here
sorry about that
here using the
cd34 in grafted animals
you can get a full reconstitution of all
the human immune cells including
monocytes macrophages and therefore you
can test therapy small molecules
molecular antibodies that are targeting
those cells here an example with mdmb2
231
treat it left untreated
with small molecules targeting the m1
and 2 macrophages balance
it works nicely significant tgi that
significant tgi is only observed in
boosted animals if you do the same
experiment in non-boosted animals you
don't get enough
macrophages in the system so no efficacy
at all so i'm really showing you the
functionality of this boosting strategy
in humanized mice
same for
nk cells so adcc related activities
can be
studied
in humanized minds an example here with
melanoma cells
cdx implanted sub-q
treated
either a therapeutic schedule meaning
that we start the treatment when a tumor
reaches 5100 cubic millimeters or a
prophylactic treatment where we start
the treatment right after engraftment
you can see that prophylactic schedule
is working even better of course because
you intervene
sooner on those animals but we take home
message here is that if you want to
target nk cells
humanized mice
can be used successfully
another example of abcc activity here
comparing
test item 3 one of the drug cover
customer to an anti-cd 38
commercially available that will target
the myeloma cells
you can see here the positive control
completely flat functionality uh two
makes per cake is great the test item
three at 20 mg per gig was not that
great but there but still we were able
to show
by flow cytometry that treatment with
test title 3 was able to upregulate
the amount of nk cells infiltrating the
tumor
car t cells
immunosafety uh efficacy of carti that
can be assessed in humanoid smiles in
collaboration with the university of
bosnia here in france we published few
years ago
this proof of concept showing that we
can isolate
the cells from the spleen of human eyes
mice those t-cells can be manufactured
to produce carti and then those cartile
can be re-injected in animals coming
from
the same cd34 donors that the one that
were sacrificed
to isolate the t-cells so in this kind
of uh study design you work in a 100
autologous way to test efficacy
and hopefully absence of immunotoxicity
of your car t
without worrying about
gvhd or
the elimination of your cartesians by
the immune system
oncolytic viruses
oncolytic bacteria can be assessed in
our facility we are equipped with bsl2
bcl3
animal and lab facility so we are
trained and authorized to work with
different biological agents
this slide to show you the comparison
between i.t
intra-tumor versus iv injection for this
virus
it works uh
as well the the two way of
administration
but we can also go a little bit deeper
into this kind of experiment and assess
the systemic immune response so to do
that what we what have been done here
and published a few years ago with
targovacs
is a first tumor
implanted on the right flank
treat treated with the oncolytic viruses
it injection
the first tumor completely disappear and
then we graft the second tumor
on the other flank
to see how the t-cells the membrane
cells are there to protect
against
the second challenge with the tumor
and that's what you can see on this wrap
the blue curve
animals pre-treated
the first time with enoncreative viruses
are significantly protected against the
growth of a second tumor on the other
flank
speaking about vaccination
in human eye smiles those animals can be
used as well to
test tumor vaccine
tumor vaccine either based on naked
tumor peptides
or nanoparticles then ridiculous load it
with
such particles
you have here an example of animals
humanized mice boosted humanized mice
vaccinated with mart one so melanoma
antigen
after few injections you start to see in
the peripheral blood clonal
amplification of cdht cells that are
specific
for mart one to do that we used
extremely staining
another example vaccinating the animal
here with prem one dendritic cells load
it with prem one has been done in
collaboration
uh a company in netherlands that would
set up a
vaccine
treatment in humanized mice
um
once again here after a few
injection of
of prem 1 dendritic cells
we can challenge those animals with
scuff tree
and observe that the the animals that
were vaccinated with the prem 1 adriatic
cells were somehow protected even if the
effect is still modest they were
protected against the growth of the
scoff tree tumor starts we can also
observe if we analyze the tears of those
of those tumors that we have a very
significant proportion of the t cells
who are frame 1 specific within the
tumor so explaining why those tumors are
growth lower here and right
cdx can be engrafted but also pdx can be
engrafted in human eye smiles to work
with pdx we have a very nice
collaboration with champions oncology
having access to their full database of
pdx very well characterized more than
1500 pdx
those pdx will optimize and develop
protocols
to grow them in humanized mines
the strategy is in two-step
we first engraft those pdx
in immunodeficient animals let the tumor
grow
resect the tumor cut the tumor in pieces
and use those pieces of tumor fresh to
engraft
humanized mice and by doing so as you
can see here we speed up uh the process
the growth of the tumor but also reduce
somehow the viability of
of growth of those different pdx
so pdx once they are implanted in
humanized mice can be of course used to
test
efficacy of different
monoclonal antibodies be specific
small molecules
you can name it
here four test candidates have been
tested in parallel
in the model of pdx in humanized mice i
can see very good
tgi but also being able to discriminate
between a better candidate and a
less good candidate in this kind of
experiment
those pdx
are as expected also infiltrated with
human immune cells and as described for
the cdx the profile of infiltration is
really depending of the pdx and the data
that we have really showed that the
steel's profile
is really mimicking what was the
original situation in the patient so we
are really one step
closer to the clinic working with pdx in
the context of humanized mice you can
see on this example that we have a lot
of macrophages we have studied the m1
and 2 macrophages balanced but little t
cells once again illustrating the fact
that
you can have different situations in
terms of infiltration and knowing well
your model is really the key
to have the best success in your
experiment
so that's once my last slide thanks
again for your attention
and thanks again to meeting biotech to
organizing this webinar with us it was a
real pleasure
i'm glad now to answer any questions
that you may have about
humanization humanized minds or the use
of those humanized mice for io research
let me know thanks a lot
thank you sebastian for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on that ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
now let's get started
our first question is did you notice
differences of response to therapy in
the presence or absence of myeloid dc
boost
yeah sure i mean the boost is really
doing
great stuff in those human life mics two
examples the first regarding the ability
to use those human eyes mice to check
the efficacy of
of innate cells for example macrophages
we have experienced with customers that
we're not able to see any significant
tgi
in non-boosted minds and by doing the
same kind of experiment in our boosted
animals they were able to show
the efficacy of the treatment
same for vaccination protocol we know
that the presence of dendritic cells
more dendritic cells in the systems
really makes a big difference in how you
can elicit a t cell response or even a
humoral response in those animals
thank you
um our next question how many samples do
you usually process at once on the
multi-max and how long does the cell
separation process take
so with the multi-max we can virtually
proceed up to 24 samples at the time
in the day today we receive cold blood
we have usually between six to ten i
would say samples to proceed and the all
process from the fecal purification to
the to the isolation the finalization of
the metabolic stem cells take between
three to four hours max
perfect
another question you mentioned the cd34
cell purity after isolation was above 90
have you also checked the cell viability
yeah sure cell viability is of course
key for us we want to graph those
animals with cells that are viable uh in
the day-to-day practice we do observed
uh most of the time a pure viability
that is above 95 percent but we never
have observed an issue regarding the
viability of the purified cells
thank you we have some great questions
coming in another one
could you do boosting of myeloid and nk
cells at the same time
yeah sure that's something that we have
optimized is the ability to have
more of everything into those boosted
animals especially important for for adc
c related activities where we know that
macrophages and nk cells can play a role
so yes we can combine the il-15 boost
with the gmc sf l3 l43 ligand or in the
same animals
without losing any
capabilities i mean any boost on the
specific sales population so yes we get
the the best of the two boosts into the
same animals regularly
thanks for that looks like we
have just a couple more questions
after the tumor dissociation were you
able to effectively analyze all your key
cell surface epitopes or have you
noticed any disruption due to the
mechanical enzymatic digestion
yeah that's a fair question that's
something that we have extensively
checked uh when we set up those
procedures that we have developed like
say in the presentation for the tumor
but also for many tissues uh into uh
into those humanized mice
it's quite rare i would say that 95
percent of the time we do not have any
issue with epitaph
from time to time we know that some
epitaph may be
affected by the the enzymatic digestion
so we can switch to just the basic
mechanical digestion without the
enzymatic step so that's also a way
when we know that we are working with
very
sensible
sensitive
targets to to mitigate that possibility
perfect thank you
um we're going to wrap it up here thank
you so much um sebastian do you have any
final comments for our audience
well we just want to thank
all the uh the assembly for attending
this seminar it was a great pleasure to
to virtually be present with you today
and present this is quite interesting
topic
if your question has been not been
answered uh feel free to contact us at
front secure bioservices directly you
can do so by by clicking on our website
at
transcribebioservices.com you will find
all the info details and many more
information about the platforms that we
have developed
perfect thank you again sebastian for
your time today and your important
research we'd also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor miltoni biotek for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions like
sebastian mentioned questions we did not
have time for today and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay and we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues and anyone who may have
missed today's live event
thanks so much until next time goodbye